[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL WOLF: It's
great to be here today,
and it's a tremendous honor to
get to chat with Jimmy Wales.
So Jimmy, why don't you come on.
So first of all, everybody
knows Jimmy Wales.
[APPLAUSE]
If you go to Wikipedia, you'll
notice that a drawing of him
or a picture of him appears
asking you to give money.
So if you're one of the
hundreds of millions
of people who go to Wikipedia
practically every day,
you'll know his face.
This is him.
It's not like Colonel Sanders.
He actually exists.
So just by a little
bit of background, so
Jimmy started Wikipedia in 2001.
He launched Wikia in 2004,
which is much more focused
on entertainment and games, and
is one of the top 20 websites
worldwide.
And in 2015, he started
the Wikipedia Foundation.
And most recently, this
year he started something
called WikiTribune with the
goal to fight fake news.
And you described it as news by
the people and for the people.
And the first time that
professional journalists
and citizen journalists
will work side by side.
So let's go back.
Let's, like, rewind back
to when you started.
You've described
the initial group
that helped you start
Wikipedia as a--
I'm quoting here-- "ragtag
band of volunteers."
If you can remember
back to then,
what was it like to start
something that has become
such a worldwide phenomenon?
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, well, I
mean, this was, you know,
in the very, very
early days of Wikipedia
we were just a really
small group of people.
And you know,
before Wikipedia, I
had a project called Newpedia,
which was the same goal,
to have a free
encyclopedia for everyone.
But I didn't really
understand online communities.
I didn't have any idea
about the concept of a wiki.
And so we organized a
very top down system
with seven stages of review
to get anything published.
And that was a failure.
It was a failure
mainly because it
was really intimidating for
anybody to get involved.
And over the course
of a year, we
had created about
two dozen entries.
I had joked, I still
keep them by my bed
and read them every night.
I will get my money's
worth someday.
MICHAEL WOLF: What were
some of the two dozen?
JIMMY WALES: What were
They were just very eclectic.
But I mean, there were
so few, and they were
very academic and so forth.
And then you know,
really realized
that that wasn't working.
And I decided to pivot--
although nobody called it pivot
back then, but--
MICHAEL WOLF: Nobody should
call it that anymore.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, exactly.
I'm about done with that word.
And launched the wiki.
And in two weeks, we had as
much work done as we had in--
well, it was actually
nearly two years.
So that was the very beginning.
And the truth is, in the
very early days, I mean,
the software was in
no kind of state.
I had downloaded a UseModWiki,
which was a Perl script.
Very simple wiki package.
It was so simple, in fact,
that there were no passwords.
So you could create a username,
but you didn't have a password.
So anybody could pretend to
be anybody, which clearly
doesn't scale very well.
So one of the first
things I did was
sort of write a password, sort
of ability to have a password.
And but still, what was great
about wikis is the word wiki,
it comes from a Hawaiian word,
wiki wiki, meaning quick.
Quick collaboration, like
people are able to just turn in.
Because although we had been
going for about two years
and hadn't gotten
much done, there
were a lot of people who were
super interested and super
excited about this concept of a
free encyclopedia for everyone.
And so we were able to
pretty quickly move forward.
But we were able to do it.
I mean, there was no, like--
again, people didn't say minimal
viable product back then.
It was just like this
crappy Perl script
and we were just sort of doing
stuff on a day-to-day basis
to try to make it better.
MICHAEL WOLF: When you
take apart Wikipedia
as you really founded
and invented it,
there's a couple
of unique things.
One of them is that
practically anybody can post.
One of the others
that isn't so apparent
is this massive community of
people who, totally unpaid,
in a lot of cases,
totally anonymous,
who edit and make sure that
every entry fits to, really,
to Wikipedia's standards.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah,
I mean, I think
there's a few elements
of that that are really
important to understand.
So first of all, you
know, the word community,
online community,
is much abused.
And oftentimes what
people mean by that
is just the general public.
But for me, when I use
the word community,
it's people who actually
know each other,
and they're discussing
and debating,
they're actually
making decisions.
And so if your mental model
of how Wikipedia works
is 100 million people
adding one sentence each
and it magically
becomes an encyclopedia,
that isn't the case.
It's really a core
group of volunteers
who enforce the rules, who
decide what the rules are,
who put into place
organized procedures
and processes to monitor
things, to update things.
Just as one example is the
concept of a WikiProject.
So one of my
favorite WikiProject
is WikiProject Bridges.
So this is a group
of people who are
really interested in bridges,
the architecture, the history.
And they go through
all of Wikipedia
and they find all the articles
having to do with bridges.
MICHAEL WOLF: These are experts?
Interested amateurs?
JIMMY WALES: A mix, actually.
So one of the guys
who I met who is
one of the leaders of
the WikiProject Bridges
is an architect.
But many of the people aren't.
They're just
interested hobbyists.
And so they go through
all these articles,
and they come up with
checklists of, OK,
what does a good bridge
article look like?
What does it need
to have included?
Which ones don't
have those elements,
and can we research
and find that?
And so there's a lot
of that kind of work
that goes on
beneath the surface.
And it really is
small groups who
know each other who
say, OK, well, we're
going to take on this
particular topic.
Another fantastic one,
particularly strong
in English Wikipedia is
WikiProject Medicine.
And they are quite
fearsome in their demands
that the rules be followed
because the medical topics are,
you know, people rely on it.
It's really important that the--
are very, very
careful about things
that could mislead the
public and so forth.
So yeah.
MICHAEL WOLF: And why
do people contribute?
Is it-- you talked
about a community
of people that know each other.
Is it a dedication to it?
Is it prestige among the
other people that they
know in this community?
JIMMY WALES: So it's
a couple of things.
So first of all, the vision--
a free encyclopedia
for every single person
on the planet in their own
language-- is exciting.
People think that's
worth spending time on.
So you know, if you're
someone, you know,
you could spend the weekend
playing Grand Theft Auto,
and then late Sunday
night you realize
you've just wasted
two days of your life
that you'll never
get back and you
haven't improved the world--
MICHAEL WOLF: It's
very productive.
JIMMY WALES: Or you
can work on Wikipedia
and whatever may come of
it, you come away thinking,
hey, you know what?
The world's a little bit better
now than it was when I started.
So that grand
vision is important.
But also, it has to be fun.
People have to find
it interesting.
You have to meet other nice,
interesting people who are,
you know, you're learning
things and you're meeting people
and you're having
quality debates, which
is hard to come by
on the internet.
There's plenty of places to
have sort of raging flame wars.
But to actually have an
interesting discussion
or debate around the
quality of sourcing
around some particular
topic, people enjoy that.
And so it's got to
be both of those.
It's got to be that
we feel like we're
doing something productive
and we also are enjoying it.
And so yeah, it
does have something
to do with, not prestige.
So if you want to become
a well-known famous person
on the internet,
I would recommend
being a blogger or
something like that.
You know, spend your
time on social media.
But so within the
Wikipedia community though,
we aren't particularly
anonymous with each other.
People do know each
other and people
have respect and people--
MICHAEL WOLF: But they
know each other virtually,
or do they actually know
each other in person?
JIMMY WALES: Mostly
virtually, but it depends.
Actually, that depends
very much on the language.
So if you think
about, for example,
Lithuanian Wikipedia, virtually
everyone who speaks Lithuanian
lives within a train
ride of each other.
And so they tend to have meetups
and they get together for beer
and they actually know
each other pretty well.
Other languages, like
English, of course,
is spread all around the world.
And so oftentimes, people
talk to each other.
But people do meet up.
They meet up locally.
They meet up all over the world.
We have our conferences
and things like that.
MICHAEL WOLF: Of course,
one of the topics--
and putting aside the last
election board on the topics
overall--
is verifying information.
And everybody's aware of some
of the famous Wikipedia hacks.
So for example, I used
to run MTV Networks,
and one of our companies
is Nickelodeon.
And there was the Wikipedia page
for both Eminem and SpongeBob
said that Eminem was
the voice of SpongeBob.
Now I can assure you,
that was not the case.
Or Stephen Colbert
from Comedy Central
convinced his audience to change
Wikipedia to say that elephants
were not endangered.
What needs to happen to
ensure that these entries,
whether it's about
popular culture
or about medicine or
about architecture,
what happens to make sure
that they are verified?
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, so just
as an example, so they--
when Colbert made
this joke on the air,
literally within 30 seconds
of him saying the joke,
the page was locked because
the Wikipedians actually
watch Colbert, too.
So the admins just went in and
locked the page immediately.
And vandalism-- and then we
had to cope with it for, like,
three weeks as people
kept trying to put it in.
But we just kept
the page locked.
I didn't have time--
you mentioned the Eminem one.
I had not heard that one.
I'm guessing that probably
only lasted in Wikipedia
for, again, a few minutes.
I think I know why.
There's actually--
I saw it on YouTube.
There's a SpongeBob and "Lose
Yourself" mash-up on YouTube.
Has like, 4 million views.
So that's probably
where it came from.
That probably became
a meme and then
people thought it was
funny to have that.
So-- and that sort of
thing, it does happen.
Usually it's very,
very short term.
And you know,
sometimes it isn't.
Sometimes you can have
vandalism in Wikipedia
that lasts much longer
than we would like.
So it isn't perfect.
But the way it works,
we have to have--
again, if you have
the model of Wikipedia
as 100 million people, all
randomly putting stuff in,
it would just be-- that's all
it would be is just nonsense.
But we have a whole bunch of
different policies, procedures.
People become admins.
They're elected
by the community.
And then they have the
ability-- and admins are not
like in most sites.
So, if you're on YouTube,
and you do something
against the rules of YouTube,
and your video gets taken down,
and you're locked
out, you actually
have no idea who did that.
Somebody mysterious, deep
in Google somewhere, did it.
Whereas in our
community, the admins
are all members of the public.
They're all volunteers.
And they monitor each other,
and there's always debates
about is this a
valid block, why did
you block this person,
et cetera, et cetera.
So they're more like police.
They're not judge,
jury, and executioner.
They have certain abilities to
block people or block pages,
but they have to justify that.
And there are ways that those
decisions can be reviewed
and overturned and so forth.
So it's like managing a good
municipal government, really.
MICHAEL WOLF: So we have 100
million users of Wikipedia
is how many people--
I mean, this number
we want to know.
How many people are
actually editing today?
JIMMY WALES: Yes, so if you take
a look at the numbers, the best
number we have right now for
the number of unique devices
that access Wikipedia in a
month is about 1.4 billion.
So that's a lot of people.
It's not 1.4 billion people,
because probably most people
in this room, for
example access Wikipedia
in a month on at least
two or three devices.
But it's a huge audience.
And then just to give the
numbers for English Wikipedia,
there's probably about
70,000 to 80,000 people
who make at least
five edits in a month,
and there's about
3,000 people who make
at least 100 edits in a month.
So it's that 3,000 who are the
really active community, who
really oversee
and manage things.
And then there's
lots of people who
just add one thing, which then
is reviewed by the community
and so forth.
MICHAEL WOLF: Pretty
extraordinary.
Those 3,000 people
who really make,
really change the world
for the rest of us.
You've talked a lot about--
JIMMY WALES: You
know, it's funny.
I was-- a few years
back, it just struck me.
I was at--
Wikimania is our
annual conference.
And I, at a dinner, I just,
with my tray, I went and sat.
And I was, oh, OK.
Look.
Here's the English
Arbitration Committee.
So this is like the Supreme
Court of the English Wikipedia.
And we're having dinner
and discussing this, that,
and the other policy.
And I left the
table, and I thought,
I get to meet a lot
of important people,
but this is probably some of the
most powerful people in media
in the world, is the English
Wikipedia Arbitration
Committee.
I mean, they make
really big decisions,
and they're a bunch of geeks.
Which is fantastic.
MICHAEL WOLF: And nobody outside
their community knows them?
JIMMY WALES: Not really.
No.
I mean, occasionally
you'll get a news article
about somebody who's had
the most number of edits
and that sort of thing.
And oftentimes the people who--
if you've had the
most number of edits,
oftentimes, they're
running a bot.
That's how you get a very
high edit count, is do spell
checking or something like that.
Not always.
And they're generally
known in the community,
but they aren't
always necessarily
the most influential or
powerful within their community.
They're just really
busy, is the main thing.
So in general, no.
Nobody really
knows who they are.
I mean, we do.
But.
MICHAEL WOLF: But you've also
talked a lot about AI machine
learning.
What role will that play
in verifying information
in the future?
JIMMY WALES: So, I
mean, what's interesting
about this is sometimes
people will ask it this way.
When do you think AI will
be able to write Wikipedia
articles?
And I say, it's
a very long time.
Or anyway, it's one of the
highest human activities,
is to write a good Wikipedia
entry, is really quite a--
I mean, once we're there,
we're at full general AI.
It's the singularity, and let's
just hope they're nice to us.
But before that,
I do think there
are some interesting things.
We have a partnership
with Jigsaw, where we--
it's AI looking at edits
and machine-learning.
I actually know very
little about it,
except it's really cool.
So on Wikipedia, if
you're logged in,
you can go to Recent
Changes, and now you
can filter the Recent
Changes, and you
can save whatever filter.
And there's different
things you can select.
So what I do--
this is with my favorite
way of filtering--
I want to see edits that
are very likely bad,
that are likely in good
faith, by new users.
So this is somebody
new to the site.
They've made an edit
which is probably bad,
but it was probably
made in good faith.
And it actually is pretty
good at finding those.
And what you do
then, the reason I
pick those is that's the
kind of people I go say hi.
Like, hi, thanks.
It looks like you're
trying to do this.
Let's-- you know.
And that's kind of amazing.
So being able to--
I think what is interesting
here is the idea of AI
basically just raising the hand.
Raising the flag for a
human to review something.
Because it often gets it wrong.
You wouldn't really want AI
policing this sort of thing.
MICHAEL WOLF: So
it's assisted review.
JIMMY WALES: It's
assisted review.
And I think that's
very useful to--
and I think this is an
area we will pursue more
in various ways.
And AI is a very broad
term, but the idea
of using much more algorithmic
approaches to bring things
to the attention of people that
you're probably interested in.
So just as an
example, to interest
new editors, what we could do
is notice what you're reading.
And so if we see, OK, every day
you're reading about World War
II, and we have over here
an article that we have
algorithmic signals is not
very good, we could say,
hey, you've been reading
a lot about World War II.
Would you like to help out?
Here's an article that
needs improvement.
MICHAEL WOLF: More
recruitment potential.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, exactly.
Or if you're editing in an area,
then we can say, oh, here's
some similar things
that you might
want to edit that need help,
and that sort of thing.
And we've been very, very human
about all that sort of thing.
We don't have much in
the way of algorithms
to look at that sort of thing.
But I think there's huge
opportunities there.
And the great thing about
assisted review or prompting
people, is it doesn't have to
be perfect to be a lot better
than nothing.
If Wikipedia starts
suggesting things
to me that I should edit, and I
think half of them are useless,
and half of them are
actually kind of interesting,
that's better than
suggesting zero to me.
So.
MICHAEL WOLF: How does the
community feel about AI?
Do they feel that they should
put some standard around it?
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're very protective of
their turf, in a certain way.
But they're also very--
these are quite geeky people.
They're interested
in technology.
They're open to saying,
yeah, there's a lot of stuff
that humans aren't very good at
that machines-- very tedious,
boring stuff.
If we can get machines
to do that stuff
and raise it to our
attention, then our work
is more effective.
Because as I said
in the beginning,
one of the reasons
people want to edit
Wikipedia is at the end of
an hour editing Wikipedia,
if you feel like you
did something useful,
that's important.
And so if I go to Wikipedia,
and I pick some obscure article
and try to improve a
couple of sentences,
I'm never quite sure, is
anybody even going to read that?
Or whatever.
But if you show me, oh,
here's a popular article
that is in poor state, OK.
I will have an
impact if I do that.
So I think people like
that sort of idea.
MICHAEL WOLF: Let's shift gears.
Let's talk about education.
So I have a personal experience.
I have two 18-year-olds,
a boy and a girl.
And they've gone through school,
and one is already in college.
And their entire time through
school, their teachers
have said, Wikipedia
is not a source.
You can't use Wikipedia.
You have to go-- and by
the way, the first place
that they go for
anything is Wikipedia,
but it's never disclosed.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
It's like, you can tell kids,
don't listen to rock and roll
music, but.
We're well past that.
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL WOLF: Right.
No, it's actually
more important.
It's what you protect
your parents from doing.
And it's your responsibility.
But coming back to what's--
what is it that Wikipedia
and other organizations
that are around information,
what's their responsibility,
and what's the opportunity?
JIMMY WALES: So for us, I mean,
we feel a very heavy burden.
If we think about--
well, 18-year-olds, right?
So Wikipedia is
now 16 years old.
So from the time they
were learning to read,
Wikipedia had existed.
And certainly in
the last five years,
five to 10 years, when
they were old enough
to start doing homework
and looking online
or following their own
intellectual interests,
whatever that might be,
they go to Wikipedia.
And so it's just part of the
infrastructure of the world,
as far as they're
concerned, which
means we have a
responsibility to make
it as good as we possibly can.
And when I say we, I include
everyone in this room.
I mean this is a--
it's a public resource.
And it's important to
know, we don't consider
it to be a goal for
Wikipedia that we
be a citable source for
18-year-olds entering college
any more than when
I was at university,
if I cited
Britannica, that would
have been considered ludicrous.
That's something--
an encyclopedia,
that's not the role it should
play in the research process.
An encyclopedia is the starting
point, not the ending point.
Particularly at
the college level,
it's like, hey, if all you're
going to do is read Wikipedia
and write a paper, I mean,
come on, this is ridiculous.
Read Wikipedia to get
oriented, but then
go to the original
sources and start
doing more interesting
intellectual work.
Now, of course, if a
13-year-old writes something
and adds a footnote
and cites Wikipedia,
I'm like, hey, progress.
At least they've
written something,
and they put in a footnote.
That's OK at a certain age.
But later on, I don't
think that-- it's not
something we aspire to.
MICHAEL WOLF: And do
you think Wikipedia
or other organizations
with Wikipedia have
more of a role in education?
I mean, education's
a huge challenge.
And not every kid
in this country
is going to get
to go to college.
What can Wikipedia and
other organizations
do to solve our
education problem?
JIMMY WALES: Well, I think one
of the things that's going on,
if you look at the trends
in formal education,
so what percentage of people
are going to college, that
moves around a very
little bit, but it's
pretty stable, and nothing
dramatic is happening there.
A few more people are
going to college, a few
less in certain places,
in certain things.
But in general, that's a
pretty well understood area.
But what is completely
changed in the last 10,
15 years is the amount
of informal learning
that people do.
That if you hear--
MICHAEL WOLF: Self-directed?
JIMMY WALES: Self-directed.
Even just ordinary things.
So if you hear,
oh, I don't know.
Blah, blah, blah,
there's something
going on called Bitcoin.
I don't really
know what that is.
If it was 25 years ago,
you would go, I don't know.
I read this article
in the paper.
I don't really get it.
Now people dig deep.
And we see this in our traffic.
People can dig deep.
All the information is there.
And that's really important.
And it doesn't result in
more degrees and so forth,
but people can
learn about anything
they want to learn
about very easily,
and that is a huge
impact on education.
I do think there's a
lot to think about.
So for us, one of
the biggest things
that we are interested
in is the growth
of Wikipedia in the languages
of the developing world.
Because of course,
there are places
in the world where people
have very limited access
to information.
So the way I think
about this is if you're
an English speaker,
one of the things
Wikipedia is the
solution to is just
narrowing down a place to go
to find basic information.
So if I type Queen
Victoria into Google,
I'm going to get, I don't
know, millions of pages.
The number one is probably
going to be Wikipedia,
and that's probably
what I wanted.
I just wanted to get the
basic story of Queen Victoria,
her life and times, da, da, da.
It's all there.
And this is because we
have a glut of information.
But if you're speaking
an obscure language
with only a million speakers
in Africa, in your language,
there's going to be--
the role of Wikipedia
is, hey, it's
the only source I have
for Queen Victoria.
It's the only place I can
go for that information.
And not yet, in many cases.
We're just really
getting started
in a lot of those languages.
So there's a lot
of work left to do.
But it's interesting how that
impact will be different.
Because instead of
saying, oh, we've
got a glut of information.
Let's summarize it in
an encyclopedia article.
It's like, we have
no information,
so let's share it with
people in this way.
MICHAEL WOLF: The nature of how
people interact with the web
is changing dramatically.
And so everyone's aware
of the voice interface,
but the reality is the digital
assistant, whether it's
Alexa or Google Assist
or OK Google, or Siri,
these are one of the
ways in which people
will access information.
How will Wikipedia adapt
to those new interfaces?
JIMMY WALES: So it
is very interesting.
I mean, we are an important part
of those interfaces already.
If you ask Alexa a
question, 99% of the time,
she's just going to
read Wikipedia to you
or get a fact from Wikipedia.
Obviously Google relies a lot
on Wikipedia for the Knowledge
Graph.
I don't actually use
the Google Assistant
because I have Alexa at home.
I assume it's very similar.
Although I heard that if you
ask Google a question, it says,
according to
Wikipedia-- thank you--
whereas Alexa just acts
like she knows everything,
even though she's just
reading it out of Wikipedia.
So there's that.
I need to email Jeff
Bezos about that.
But.
But what's interesting for us--
MICHAEL WOLF: And Siri
asked you the question.
JIMMY WALES: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
I don't know.
I try-- Siri didn't
understand what I was saying.
So you know.
So in any event, basically,
what's interesting to us
about that is--
and one of the areas that we
do slightly worry about it,
but we don't have
firm evidence yet--
one of the worries we have is--
and we're not a business.
We're a charity.
So we don't think much
about business model,
and we've never been
very good at thinking
about business model.
We just are a
group of people who
are enjoying making
this encyclopedia,
and we're really happy
that everybody likes it.
But realistically, we do
have to think about that.
So right now, the way
Wikipedia gets money to survive
is you come to the website,
and there's a little banner.
Very rarely, but
once a year you see--
MICHAEL WOLF: Your photo does
very well in terms of getting--
JIMMY WALES: It--
yeah, we haven't
been using it in recent years.
I'm very happy.
We found this ugly yellow banner
that no one on Madison Avenue
would think would work,
but it works beautifully.
And actually, we are--
more and more, our fundraising
is through the email campaign.
Because our donors
are very loyal.
And if you donate
to Wikipedia, a year
later, you get a message from
me, which I may or may not
have actually written, that
says, hey, it's been a year.
Time to cough up again.
And it gets a really
good response.
And so that's the good news.
What we worry about is--
I call it the "how old
is Tom Cruise" problem.
So five years ago,
10 years ago, if you
typed, "how old is Tom
Cruise" into Google,
the first link was Wikipedia.
And you go there, and you find
out how old was Tom Cruise.
Now the first link is still
Wikipedia, but up above that,
it tells you how old Tom Cruise
is, because Google understands
the world much better.
Google read Wikipedia,
for one thing.
And so we think, OK.
But does that mean we're
not seeing that traffic,
and does that mean
we're not going to get
the donations from people?
So far, we don't have
any evidence of that.
And in fact, because the
Knowledge Graph does link
to Wikipedia--
I mean, we see a lot
of traffic from that.
So it hasn't yet hurt us.
But when we think then
about a voice assistant,
if people are just
saying, who is Tom Cruise?
And you get three
sentences from Wikipedia,
and people don't know
where it's from--
MICHAEL WOLF: So you're
concerned about attribution.
JIMMY WALES: Concerned
about attribution.
But even if there
is attribution,
are people going to donate?
We don't know.
So far, so good.
But that is one thing.
And our view is, again,
the fundamental--
the vision statement
for Wikipedia
is, imagine a world in
which every single person
on the planet is given
free access to the sum
of all human knowledge.
That's what we're doing.
And so in that front,
and the community's view
on this sort of thing, is
it's fucking fantastic.
Like, amazing.
Wikipedia is part of the
infrastructure of the world.
All these new technologies
are coming out.
The knowledge that we've
carefully stewarded and written
is now helping people--
When did Fred
Astaire die, right?
You have this thought in
your kitchen for two seconds,
and you ask Alexa, and she
tells you, amazing, right?
We don't need to
get paid for that.
That's what we're a charity for.
We want everybody to
have access to knowledge.
But there is a little
bit of a question
about, OK, how does our business
model work if in 20 years,
as technology changes,
we don't want to let
Wikipedia get left behind?
But so far, we're doing
great financially.
So we always run it in
a very conservative way.
We ask for money.
Sometimes we're getting
criticism from, I think,
rather stupid press outlets,
who say, why is Wikipedia
begging for money?
They have $100
million in the bank.
And it's like, well, our annual
budget is about $70 million,
so we have about
18 months reserve.
That's considered to be a
healthy level of reserves
for a nonprofit.
We're not apologetic about that.
But every year, we've been--
last year-- well,
thanks to the president,
who is not necessarily
a big fan of us,
but who has motivated
people to care
about knowledge, in a
roundabout way, from the day
after the election, we
saw a massive increase
in donations, which was
very heartwarming to see.
Because you know.
And we'll get on to
fake news in a bit
when we're talking
about WikiTribune.
But we've decided we're also
raising an endowment fund.
Because we do think of
ourselves not so much as a--
I mean, we're not a dot.com.
We're not a tech startup.
We're a charity
sharing knowledge,
and we try to think
in the long run.
And so one of the
things we say is, look,
while we're not in desperate
financial situation,
we should be thinking
about the long-term future.
So we've now got--
we're raising $100
million endowment fund.
And I think we've got pledges
for about $17 million so far.
And it's really the first
time that we've really
tried to have more of
a major donor campaign.
Because the vast majority
of the money for Wikipedia
comes from those--
you see the banner,
and you give $20.
And that's the vast
majority of the money.
And we've never been really
good at doing major donor stuff,
but we think this is
an interesting product,
you might call it,
for a major donor
to say, don't just
fund our annual budget,
think about the future.
We want Wikipedia and
the idea of Wikipedia
to be safe in the long run.
So we want to have this fund
for any future emergencies
or any future opportunities.
And we've done it
all the right way.
We've got a separate
board, so there's
another layer of
governance, so it's not just
a big bank account for
some future profligate CEO
and so forth.
So, so far, so good.
MICHAEL WOLF: I'm going to
ask everybody for questions
a little later, so please
start thinking about them.
But in the meantime, I'd like
to welcome Orit Kopel, who's
your co-founder of WikiTribune.
JIMMY WALES: Yes.
Fantastic.
MICHAEL WOLF: Orit,
you're somewhere?
JIMMY WALES: Orit,
there she comes.
[APPLAUSE]
ORIT KOPEL: Hi.
MICHAEL WOLF: Welcome.
ORIT KOPEL: Thank you.
MICHAEL WOLF: So what should
we know about WikiTribune?
JIMMY WALES: Do
you want to start?
I have to let her start, because
I'm terrible about just--
I can just sit here and talk.
ORIT KOPEL: Well, how many of
you have heard of WikiTribune?
Oh, that's great.
OK.
It's Google here, so.
It's a new, inventive
news platform
which involves
journalism in a way that
has never been done before
by bringing together
a Wiki-based community
of volunteers
and hired professional
journalists in an effort
to create a
collaborative news space.
A high-quality, open platform
which is generally community
controlled and have the backbone
of professional journalists.
And so we practically attend
the community of volunteers
and the hired
journalists as equals.
And it is a Wiki-based
platform, so everyone can edit
every article on our website.
MICHAEL WOLF: So--
but how do you
ensure freedom of expression?
And this is not just-- this
isn't just journalists.
These are individuals who are
today posting to social media.
First of all, what do we
need to protect them from?
And how do we ensure expression?
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, one
thing I wanted to explain.
Because there was a little
error in the introduction, so.
In 2015, I didn't set up
the Wikipedia Foundation.
The Wikipedia Foundation has
been around for a long time.
In 2015, I set up the
Jimmy Wales Foundation
for Freedom of Expression, which
is a nonprofit based in the UK.
What we do is we fight for--
mainly for social media users.
So people who aren't covered.
So Reporters Without
Borders does a fantastic job
of working to highlight cases
of journalists being arrested,
but a lot of times, ordinary
people who say something
and get themselves arrested,
a political speech,
get a bit ignored.
And so we try to campaign for
those people, and so forth.
And Orit is the CEO of the
Jimmy Wales Foundation.
And that's a separate piece
of work from WikiTribune,
which is a new project.
Jim Wales Foundation,
what happened there,
I went to Dubai to
give a speech, as I do.
And when I landed, they
said, oh, congratulations.
The leader of Dubai
has decided to give you
a half a million dollars
as the Knowledge Award.
And I was like, OK.
Fine.
That sounds all right.
But then I went back to
my room, and I was like,
you know, I'm super critical
of Dubai on human rights
issues, freedom of
expression, and so forth.
So I can't in good conscience
take this money and buy a boat.
And so that was when I said, OK.
I'm going to take the money,
which is from a bad source,
in my opinion.
I don't want to
give it back to him
so he can hire more
people to beat bloggers.
Instead I'll use it to fight
for freedom of expression.
So that's when we started
working together on that.
And so that's been great fun.
MICHAEL WOLF: OK.
So then explain
WikiTribune, please.
JIMMY WALES: All right.
So WikiTribune.
So WikiTribune, we
just started this year.
Orit gave the basic concept of
it, a little of the history.
We decided to launch using
a crowdfunding campaign.
And I really am a big
fan of crowdfunding.
As an entrepreneur
starting something new,
I could have easily gone and
raised money in Silicon Valley
to do it, but I don't know
if the public is interested.
Do they want this?
And so saying to people, hey,
will you sign up to contribute?
And the business model
is we asked people
to become monthly supporters.
We have no paywall
and no advertising.
So a series of bad business
decisions, but it's
how I've built my career so far.
But I didn't know.
I'm like, will that even work?
Will people be interested?
So we did a
crowdfunding campaign.
Not on Kickstarter or
anywhere like that,
we just did it independently.
And we got a great--
you know, I said, look.
I need enough money to hire
10 journalists and some tech
people.
And so we managed to do that.
We also got a lovely
grant from Google.
Google Digital News
Initiative, in Europe,
to develop the software.
We're taking WordPress
as a platform
and turning it into a wiki.
And as it turns out, WordPress
doesn't want to be a wiki.
So there's a lot
of beating on it
to make that more
useful in that regard.
And we went into closed
beta for a while,
and then now, just two
weeks ago, we've opened--
you can go and sign up, and
you can start editing things.
And we've got now 13
journalists hired--
some of them are part-time,
but 10 full-time equivalents--
around the world, but mostly in
London, which is where I live.
And that's where we are today.
And we are publishing stories.
So go to WikiTribune,
and you can see it.
MICHAEL WOLF: So what
is-- just for this group
to understand-- what is the
problem that WikiTribune solves
versus what
Wikipedia does today?
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
So Wikipedia is not news.
There's a page on Wikipedia
that says, not news.
We're not news.
Now, of course,
Wikipedia, quite famously,
does update very quickly
when news events happen,
but it doesn't cover every
single thing as it's happening.
And also at Wikipedia, one
of the fundamental rules
is no original research.
And so everything
in Wikipedia should
have been published in a
high-quality, third-party
source.
But to do journalism--
journalism, by definition,
is original research.
It's actually going
out and getting
new stories, new information.
What I'm hopeful for, and
the concept behind this
is to say, look, if we can
find a way for a community
to usefully and
productively help out
with the process
of journalism, it
lowers the costs significantly.
And by lowering the
cost significantly,
that means of the money we
get from readers, more of it
can be spent on journalists.
If I was on the board of "The
Guardian"-- and "The Guardian"
has lots and lots
of journalists.
It's a fantastic paper.
But they've got a lot
of people doing things
inside "The Guardian"
that I know people
would enjoy doing themselves.
There's no reason to pay
staff to do something
that people would enjoy doing
if they're invited to do it.
And one of those
things, for example,
is policing for
neutrality, which
is something that most
newspapers these days are
very, very bad at.
MICHAEL WOLF: So explain to--
what do you mean by neutrality?
JIMMY WALES: Neutrality.
Well, you're familiar
with it from Wikipedia.
Wikipedia tries very
hard to be quite neutral
and succeeds, for the most part.
And most media outlets
these days don't even try.
I mean, a few do.
Good quality papers
still try to be neutral.
I don't think-- if we think
of neutrality, I mean,
we've been criticized
on the neutrality front
from both the right and the
left at WikiTribune already.
So Breitbart had a really nasty
article about WikiTribune.
And I was like, right.
MICHAEL WOLF: Not living to
their standard of neutrality.
JIMMY WALES: Not living
to Breitbart's standard
of neutrality.
No, it was basically
saying we were obviously
a bunch of lefties, and so on.
And then we had a left-wing
journalist saying, obviously,
there's no such thing as truth.
So I'm exaggerating.
But basically,
everybody-- the simple way
to understand it
philosophically is everybody
knows what bias looks like.
You know?
If we mention Breitbart
and neutrality
in the same sentence,
we all chuckle,
because we know they don't
even try to be neutral.
Same with the "Daily
Mail," for example.
And frankly, the same
with "The Guardian."
I love "The Guardian,"
but they're not
a neutral newspaper.
They come from a particular
liberal position.
And the idea is to
say, look, actually,
you should try to
just report the facts
in a very neutral manner.
And it's important
to really try.
Will you get there perfectly?
Of course not.
Not every time.
But one of the ways that you
can get there is if you do
have a healthy
community, who aren't
just people screaming at each
other, who are saying, yeah.
Actually, we've
got some diversity
in the community to make sure
that we're not just focusing
on one side of the issue.
We're actually
taking into account
the best arguments of the other
side, et cetera, et cetera.
MICHAEL WOLF: So please
get your questions ready.
I have one more question
for Jimmy and Orit,
and then we'll open it up.
So there are 3,000 people
in the Wikipedia world
who are probably
the most important,
and they're important
for everybody.
There's also a-- and
they're known to each other.
There's also a set of
people in the world who
are maybe equally
or more important,
and those are the
people who create
the algorithm for Google.
What should Google
take away from what
you've been able to
accomplish and the way
you see the world going forward
in terms of information?
JIMMY WALES: Oh, I don't know.
[LAUGHS] I mean, I--
that's a really-- it's
a really tough problem.
I mean, so one of the
things that I think--
I don't know.
I have no idea.
That's a really tough question.
I'll just comment
somewhere near that.
So I was part of a
group that Google
asked to help and be
advising about the "Right
to Be Forgotten"
in Europe, which
was a huge deal in Europe.
This is Orit and I
were working together.
She was helping me write
stuff for Google and so forth.
And the issue there is that in
Europe, the state of the law
is really, it's a disaster
for freedom of expression.
It's really not appropriate.
And the problem is
the law that has
been applied by the courts is
actually older than Google.
The particular case
that went through
was a lawyer in Spain had had
some sort of a tax problem,
and his house had
been taken from him
and had to be auctioned.
And he-- and this was
covered in the papers.
It was actually
an official notice
from the courts that
was in the papers.
It's still published
in that paper,
but Google is not
allowed to link to it,
on the grounds that it's out
of date, irrelevant, et cetera.
Now, to me, that's
not irrelevant
at all if my lawyer has had his
house taken for tax reasons.
That's probably
important for me to know.
But so there you have it.
So it's really a bad thing.
But there are other
cases where you can
be a little more sympathetic.
Revenge porn, things
like that, where
if Google is linking to
it, that's problematic.
My belief is that any demand
to take down content or a link
to content should
go through a judge.
It shouldn't be--
the way it is now,
Google is mandated to be
judge, jury, and executioner
on these things.
And there's not--
for publishers,
there's not a really
clear right of appeal.
And Google shouldn't
have that responsibility.
Google, I think,
takes it seriously
to try to do the right thing,
but it's just not the--
public policy-wise, it's
not the right answer.
But one of the things I
said to Eric Schmidt, when
we were going around
doing this, is I said--
we were doing hearings
around Europe.
Hearings from all
kinds of experts
on all sides of the issue.
I said, I wish we were doing
these hearings two years ago,
before it became a
legal court issue.
Because I actually think this
is a search quality issue that,
for Google, you
don't really want
to be linking to revenge porn.
You really want to have
a well-understood and
well-developed editorial policy.
And of course,
Google traditionally
has kind of been a
little reluctant to say,
we choose to link to things
we think are quality.
We're like "The New York Times."
We have a right of
freedom of expression.
Instead, Google has preferred
to go, mm, it's the algorithm.
And I think that may have been--
I'm not a lawyer,
so I don't know
why that approach was taken.
I think it may have
been a mistake.
Because I do think, for a
lot of the kinds of things
that Google is linking
to or shouldn't
be linking to, rather than
having the law dictate it,
most of the time, I
think Google should just
make those decisions
to say, yeah,
we're not going to
link to revenge porn.
So if there's a revenge
porn link out there,
and we're notified, we're
going to take that link down.
Which I think they do now.
But.
MICHAEL WOLF: Great.
Well, this is a good
transition to questions.
If your questions-- there are
two microphones on either side,
since we need this
to go on video.
Questions.
Does anybody have questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering what
the relationship was
between WikiTribune
and Wikipedia
or what the intended
goal relationship is?
JIMMY WALES: Yes.
So WikiTribune is a
completely new organization,
and there is no
relationship at all.
I'm on the board of
both, but that's it.
And the reason I did it
that way, one of the things
that's fantastic about
the world of Wikipedia
is that all decisions get made
through a very long process
of community consultation
and deliberation,
which means we're very
slow at making decisions,
but we tend to make
very good decisions.
This is a startup where
I'm going to have to change
the website like 10
times quite radically,
as we figure out what's
working, what isn't.
And it wasn't really
possible to even launch
something like this--
it would be a massive, sort
of two-year consultation,
and I wanted to
just move quickly.
So that's why we're
doing it this way.
MICHAEL WOLF: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Jimmy.
Thanks very much for an
interesting conversation.
You mentioned that
you live in London.
I think the foundation
is based in the UK.
The UK also has famously
restrictive and gruesome libel
laws that massively restrict
freedom of expression.
Is there any kind of risk
to the foundation for that?
Or is there some kind
of irony in there?
To base it right there?
JIMMY WALES: OK.
So the Jimmy Wales
Foundation is based
in the UK, a completely
separate organization.
We have too many organizations.
WikiTribune is based in the UK.
And then the
Wikimedia Foundation,
which runs Wikipedia,
is in California.
So on the libel law
front for WikiTribune,
the law has changed
recently in the UK.
It's become a lot better,
but it's still by no means
as good as in the US.
But I'm not that
worried about it
because we want to be really
very high-quality, very
neutral, very fact-based.
Obviously, there's always a
risk of a lawsuit, of course.
But if the "Daily
Mail" can survive
without being sued
out of existence,
I imagine we'll be all right.
MICHAEL WOLF:
Right here, please.
AUDIENCE: What's your
plans for scope and scale
of the first year?
How many stories
on an average day
would you want to have
up on WikiTribune?
JIMMY WALES: I
don't really know.
We want to have--
ORIT KOPEL: As much as possible.
JIMMY WALES: As
much as possible,
but without
compromising quality.
So there are a lot of
interesting open questions.
So right now, because
we've just launched,
basically, what we say is that
the community and the staff
are equals, but that
doesn't mean that everybody
is the editor in chief.
And so we do have editors
who approve things
before they're published, and
they treat the journalists
and the staff as
equal in that regard.
So right now, we're
being a little bit slow
about what we're
putting out, because we
want it to be good quality.
Part of that is I
wouldn't do it this way
if I weren't a well-known
person already.
But I know that a
lot of people who--
at the "Daily
Mail," for example,
are just waiting for us to
publish some error to just sort
of take us down a notch.
And we'd rather be--
MICHAEL WOLF: You're
held to a high standard.
JIMMY WALES: Held
to a high standard
from day one, whereas Wikipedia
was not held to a high standard
from day one, because nobody
knew what we were doing.
Nobody cared.
They were like, they're
a tiny little group
of people in an obscure
corner of the internet.
Eventually, though,
I think we want
to open it up to have stories
published quite quickly.
A lot of open-ended things.
I'm happy to have
short, little stub
articles that are just quick
updates rather than a fully
composed piece.
But to be determined.
To be determined.
MICHAEL WOLF: So we're going
to take another one here.
We have two more here.
I just want to
make sure everyone
gets their questions
answered, because we're
going to run out of time.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Jimmy.
I used to do some work on
the Wikipedia Signpost,
and I was wondering to
what extent that may
have influenced WikiTribune?
The Wikipedia Signpost, for
those of you who don't know,
is an on-Wikipedia
sort of newspaper
that's been around
for at least a decade.
Probably a decade and a half.
JIMMY WALES: To
some extent, yeah.
Because it's a--
I mean, obviously,
I read the Signpost.
And it sort of goes
into my thinking
about what communities can do.
And the Signpost,
generally it reports
on internal goings-on
at Wikipedia,
as well as things that would
be of interest to the community
outside, and tries to be
neutral and fair and so on.
And I think it's quite
good, but I can't
say it directly inspired me.
But obviously, it's
just a part of my world.
Yeah.
MICHAEL WOLF: Here, please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'd like to go back on
fact-checking on Wikipedia,
if you could comment a bit more.
What happens when
somebody edits obscure,
difficult to check
facts, like for example,
we have census data for
some small county in the US,
let's say, which is not
easy to check, and maybe--
does that trigger--
signal an email
to the moderators,
or do you have a
minimum amount of edits
that need to be done before that
triggers an alert that perhaps
somebody is making
significant changes?
I'd specifically
like to understand
how you check numbers, because
I use that in my project.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
So generally, there's
not much algorithmic
signaling of people.
So editors have a
watch list, and they
can flag the things they
are interested to watch,
and then they're notified
when something changes there.
Normally what we would say is
we will ask for the source,
so then you'd have to
link to the source.
And it may be hard
to find the source,
but once you've
found the source,
and you've linked to it, it's
quite easy for other people
to go and evaluate
it and say, oh, well,
this is from the
government of this area.
It was published at this date.
It seems like legit information,
and that sort of thing.
It's quite
old-fashioned, really.
There's nothing--
AUDIENCE: Sometimes these
sources aren't online, though.
So like, I've seen census
data from the 1800s.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah, yeah.
So for sources
that aren't online,
we consider that to be valid.
There's no rule--
I actually sometimes
get quoted--
I find it incredibly annoying--
I get quoted, and people love
to make these beautiful kind
of placards with this quote,
saying, "if it isn't in Google,
it doesn't exist."
OK, those words came
out of my mouth only
to make fun of that
view of the world.
And so I'm like, that's
not really fair to quote me
as saying that.
So basically, there's
nothing special.
Nothing I can really tell you.
If you're a well-known
contributor,
and you're known to be someone
who works in that area,
and you're trusted
by the community,
that would be
completely accepted.
If the information
you're putting in
seems in some way
surprising, so you're
saying the population
of Miami, Florida
was 43 million
people in 1870, we'd
probably go, yeah, probably
not, and challenge it.
And then in between, I think
we would tend to trust.
If it's obscure,
like, what motive
would you have for making
up population numbers?
That's a question that would
go through people's minds.
And the source, there will
be people in Wikipedia
who their hobby is population
figures in the 1800s.
And they will have some idea
as to whether it corroborates
with the general da, da, da.
Nothing magical about it.
It's just trying to do
the best job we can.
MICHAEL WOLF: I'm sorry.
I want to just get through
the rest of the questions.
Please go ahead.
JIMMY WALES: They're trying
to throw a question to you.
AUDIENCE: So this relates to
the previous question on scope.
But a significant way in which
news sources express bias
is not only the tone
of the articles,
but also which stories
they choose to cover
and what prominence they
choose to assign them.
So is there any way
that WikiTribune
plans to address this issue?
JIMMY WALES: I
think this is where
having a healthy and diverse
community is very helpful.
Because community members can
start stories about anything
they want.
And so the problem of a small
team of an editorial board
who have a certain
perspective on the world--
even if they're trying
to be neutral, obviously.
One of the facts about
bias is oftentimes,
we are biased in ways
that we don't even
notice because that's
what bias is, right?
And so having a diverse
community who says,
hey, we need to
write about this,
this is an important
story that's
not being covered
elsewhere, and they
can rally volunteers to
do that, then they should.
And I think we have to be
very introspective, always,
about our internal
staff processes to say,
are we just choosing stories--
you know, like in today's
political environment,
you might only choose stories
about Donald Trump and Russia
and not choose stories about
Hillary and her emails.
That's just one simple example.
To say, no, you've always got
to challenge yourself and say,
right.
We need to make sure
we're looking at things.
Because actually, one of the--
I have a whole little
rant about Fox News.
And I haven't lived in
the US in a long time.
For eight years.
And even before that, I wasn't
a big watcher of Fox News,
because I don't watch
much television.
But one of the things I think a
lot of people missed when they
thought Fox News was
incredibly biased,
which of course, it
is in certain ways,
is most of the shows people
talked about are opinion shows.
It's Bill O'Reilly pontificating
and having guests in.
But their straight news
segments were actually
quite high quality, but
they often covered stories
that people in the
Heartland cared about,
that people in New
York and California
weren't that interested in.
And that was one of the reasons
they became very popular.
They would cover
a story that just
seemed like, you know, whatever
factory workers out of work
somewhere.
Maybe "The New York
Times" covers it,
but they were really
in there, in a way.
And I think that's
important because one
of the reasons I think we've
had this huge drop in trust
in the media is a lot of
people read quality media,
and they're like, this--
I don't know.
This has nothing
to do with my life.
Nobody's really covering it.
And when we look at the
incredible devastation that's
happened to local
newspapers everywhere,
you can actually see why people
feel like, hey, journalism
doesn't care about me.
They're basically-- all
they do is rant about Trump.
Nobody is concerned
about our problems here.
So.
MICHAEL WOLF: We have like
two speed-dating questions.
So let's take the
two questions here.
And if we can, we'll
just take one more.
I'm really concerned about time.
They're starting to like--
AUDIENCE: Can you let
your partner speak on--
JIMMY WALES: I would love to.
Yes.
Every question, they say,
Jimmy, da, da, da, da.
Let's ask Orit some questions.
MICHAEL WOLF: OK, Orit.
JIMMY WALES: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
This question is for
Orit, explicitly.
It seems to me, part of
the success of Wikipedia
is the quality of the community.
How at WikiTribune are you going
about building the community
and making sure it is a
productive environment?
Thank you.
ORIT KOPEL: So first of all,
we're welcoming everyone,
and we're welcoming all of you.
We are lucky to
have Jimmy to have
the experience of building
an online community
of contributors.
So we are also aware of
all the possible problems
that might occur.
We don't want to be UK-based
or US-based or Euro--
just West-centric.
That's why we plan to launch in
as many languages as possible
and in as many regions as
possible, to start dissolving--
the all focus on--
and you were talking
about Trump and Hillary.
There are so many more stories
around the world happening.
You have terror attacks in Egypt
and so on, that people do talk,
but maybe not enough.
Maybe a lot of
corruptions in different,
you know, in Colombia
and different countries,
that I don't think
they get enough focus.
That's why personally-- I have
the background of human rights
law, so personally, I'm
very interested in having
a very diverse community
from different backgrounds,
for gender-wise.
I know that Wikipedia has some
problem with not enough women
editing the entries.
So we are very aware
of the problems that
were or still
exist in Wikipedia,
and we're trying to
avoid them or solve them
before they happen.
And so it is a
challenge, of course.
I don't have all
the answers yet.
But we can adopt some of the
solutions that were already
found in Wikipedia, and
maybe we will find new ones.
Diversity, I think
it's very important
for the neutrality part
that Jimmy spoke about,
but for many more things
that are important for a very
successful news site that's
going to attend all issues
and relate to as many
people as possible.
We want to change journalism.
We don't want to replicate
what already exists.
MICHAEL WOLF: So
we are going to--
I know I'm running overtime.
They're going to
get the hook soon.
But I want to make sure we
get [INAUDIBLE] questions.
Amazing duck sweater.
Please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I guess bringing
it back to a Wikipedia question.
You've mentioned how
important the community is,
and you kind of just mentioned
some of the maybe biases
or differences about that.
A specific question
I had is, do you
think that the community
of contributors
is going to be aging
over time with Wikipedia,
or are you seeing a lot of
newer, younger people come in?
Comment, I guess, if you
have any insight into other--
any kind of diversity there.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
In terms of Wikipedia, the--
it's a concern, but it's
not an overwhelming concern.
So we do see--
we've got a very large
cohort of very active, very
powerful users who've been
around for a long time,
but we also have
new contributors
who come in all the time.
We don't have good
data on the aging.
My feeling is that the Wikipedia
community has been aging--
sort of the average
age has been going up
about a quarter of a year every
year, or something like that.
So we are aging, but
it's not like we're
all-- we're not going
up by one year per year.
So there is that.
And yeah.
MICHAEL WOLF: Final
question, please.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So my question is
just around fake news.
And a large part of
the fake news problem
is that people
are just consuming
news in an echo chamber.
So I'm just curious
about how WikiTribune
plans to tackle that,
and any other thoughts
you have around that.
ORIT KOPEL: I think I
just talked about that.
That we are going to
attend more communities.
And also going to local
communities as well.
We're searching
for a lot of models
to get as many diverse people
and communities and backgrounds
involved.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
I think one of the
key elements here
and one of the reasons
we're launching with no ads
is the advertising model
drives a certain sameness
to the stories that are covered.
If you're chasing
clicks, you need
to have a headline
about something
that people are already
excited about and know about,
so you're going to
get a lot more clicks.
Our business model,
what I need, I
need you to read to the bottom
of a piece and say, wow.
I didn't see that anywhere else.
I understand the world
better than I did before.
This deserves to exist.
I should chip in.
I should pay for this.
Versus if I were ad-driven, I
just need you to come and look.
And that means it
doesn't drive you
in the direction of trying to
wow people with like, oh wow,
I didn't know about that,
and how did I miss that?
This is something new.
So I think that's a
part of the answer,
is to set up the business model
so that the organization's
internal focus is on
something different from what
everybody else is doing.
MICHAEL WOLF: So this has
been a great conversation.
We could go on for a long time.
And I'm sure the folks at
Google really appreciate it.
Thank you both.
JIMMY WALES: Yeah.
Thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE]